die sendung nach der bundestagswahl und
das undenkbare ist plötzlich denkbar
geworden eine regierung ohne die union
ju news ist doch wieder die natur leute
vögel fallen tot vom himmel sage ich
doch die erde tut sich auf und er bricht
lavaströme wahrscheinlich aus protest
gegen gerade mal 24,1 prozent für cdu
und csu zusammen
ok nichts davon ist passiert zugegeben
gott ist es scheinbar völlig egal dass
die christlichen parteien deutschlands
um ihre nackte existenz kämpfen nicht
übertrieben armin laschet holt das
schlechteste unions ergebnis seit dem
urknall und will trotzdem kanzler werden
weil wir ja weil er deshalb will und
sonst keinen job mehr für ihn frei ist
es fast schon tragisch und im grunde
absehbar denn vielleicht haben sie es
gesehen es gab ja ohne ende böse omen
schon am wahlmorgen armin kommt von
kameras begleitet top gelaunt aus seiner
haustür und dann
aber kurz danach war das dann allen
gezeigt also wasser gewählt hat hat er
allen gezeigt ja es war halt einfach
nicht sein tag beziehungsweise seien ja
und selbstverständlich ist das nicht
alles laschet schuld logisch ohne angela
merkel ist die cdu nur noch ein
großes geheimnis nichts und das hat die
ganze partei über jahre zugelassen von
masken affäre und so mal ganz zu
schweigen kurz gesagt es liegt nicht nur
an armin und man hätte ja fast mitleid
wenn er nicht noch am wahlabend
durchgedreht wäre und wir als union
haben von unseren wählerinnen und
wählern einen klaren auftrag erhalten
genau und zwar den klaren auftrag euch
in die opposition zu verfassen zwar ist
das schon realitätsverlust leidet der
mann unter sowas wie morbus trump
ernsthaft das hatte doch echt einen
hauch von schröder in der elefantenrunde
2005 und der war wenigstens besoffen was
ist armins ausrede und wie wäre es denn
auch spaß mal mit einem schüsschen demut
also olaf scholz und ich finde ich zur
gleichen demut aufgerufen
ich finde ich nicht was ist denn los mit
dem typen das ging wirklich schon in den
bereich kleinkind verhalten oder von ihr
hier müssen aber gleich demütig sein ja
eben nicht hier ich erkläre es nochmal
kindgerecht mit dem heute show pantomime
rasch mal auf armin die spd hat über
fünf prozent dazu gewonnen
eine union hat über acht prozent
verloren
[Musik]
deswegen musst du viel demütiger sein
als der urlaub
und nächste woche erklären werde dann
wie man richtig zurücktritt
weil deine zahlen so unglaublich in den
keller gehen
ja danke an unseren festangestellten
pantomime für was tritt man in dieser cd
überhaupt noch zurück für was außer der
jungen union sachsen und 34
hinterbänklern traut sich keiner den
offenen aufstand in dem laden niemand
spricht das offensichtliche aus gut dann
mache ich das wo ist mein name in cam
us-armee es ist vorbei reise nach
jerusalem die musik ist zu ende alle
stühle sind besetzt alter du hast allein
1,3 millionen stimmen an die spd
verloren eure fraktion hat 50 mandate
weniger und du wirst trotzdem eine
zukunfts koalition bilden du hast aber
gar keine zukunft mehr also politisch
natürlich ja ich weiß mein motto nach
niederlagen war immer einfach sitzen
bleiben dann vergessen einen die leute
aber diesmal hast du es halt total
verbockt aber ich bin armin laschet und
darauf können sie sich verlassen
ja mach ich aber darum geht es jetzt gar
nicht hamidou und die union ihr seid
abgewählt euch hilft jetzt nur noch 1
ihr müsst in der opposition ihre innere
mitte wiederfinden durchschnaufen
chillen pause machen wir empfehlen das
burnout sanatorium hinten sehen für
ausgebrannte parteien ja ideal können du
und der söder jeden morgen beim partner
tai chi wieder zueinander finden oder
noch besser ihr buch den kurs wir
töpfern uns endlich ein neues
unions-programm mann armin habe mir zu
das hier ist eine intervention und wenn
du mir nicht glaubst dann hör auf diesen
alten freund dein arbeitsplatz fällt weg
geh nach hause
wir brauchen dich nicht mehr
ja zugegeben das klingt jetzt etwas hart
ist aber irgendwie war noch mal der
ganze niedergang von cdu und csu ist
eine gemeinschaftsproduktion und
wesentlich dazu beiträgt auch dieser
mann markus ich mag dich bist du holz
söder hat nie aufgehört an laschet
öffentlich rum zu sägen und damit
natürlich der union schwer geschadet
dafür hatte aber gerade bei sat 1 den
deutschen comedypreis gewonnen und zwar
in der neuen kategorie
heucheln hart an der grenze
ich glaube sogar historisch gesehen bin
ich eine der freundlicheren
csu-vorsitzenden zumindest was unsere
gemeinsame ist verhältnis mit der cdu
biete
genau freundlichster csu-vorsitzender
das macht ungefähr soviel sind wie
schönste magen darm grippe markus söder
hat endgültig das ruder übernommen in
der union bzw dem was davon übrig ist
was man so hört er ist jetzt der
bestimmer wie wir als kinder gesagt
hätten zb bei terminen für jamaika
gespräche bei der terminfindung laschet
hatte ja den samstag vorgeschlagen jetzt
ist aber morgen abend nicht gerade
angesprochen der achtzigsten geburtstag
von edmund stoiber die geburtstagsparty
plus samstag die csu-basis konferenzen
und bei beiden hat wohl markus söder
gesagt nur das geht vor das ist
wichtiger natürlich natürlich ist der
geburtstag von opa stoiber wichtiger als
deutschland sowie da spielt er wie schön
dass du geboren bist auf der blockflöte
es wird toll derweil feiert sich die spd
für ihren erdrutschsieg
25,7 prozent
das ist fast die absolute mehrheit also
gefühlt ein riesenerfolg für den besten
merkel imitator des jahres und wem
verdanken die sozen vor allem ihren
triumph vor allem den über 60 jährigen
wählern ja die haben der union
tatsächlich die alten abgejagt hier
original bilder von der wählerwanderung
deutschland ist und bleibt eben eine
geronto kratie müssen sie und die spd
ist beck mit der linken fraktion aller
zeiten klar am ende war es wohl
hauptsächlich der scholz faktor wiesmann
und nicht zu sagen nur der spaßfaktor
aber auch das darf man ja ruhig
ausgelassen feiern im rahmen seiner
möglichkeiten hier olaf eskaliert heute
abend wenn sie sich in mir
zu viele dinge zu tun heute wird es wohl
noch nichts aber ich werde mir mal ein
bild das nicht an
unterdessen
setzte für die ewigkeit ich werde mir
mal ein bier gönnen das nicht nicht ohne
alkohol ist ach du altes party animal
was man lieber auf dass es am ende eine
koalition gibt die nicht ohne spd ist
noch ist alles offen an diesem
wochenende treffen sich in berlin ja im
grunde alle alle mit allen zum
fröhlichen rum sondieren wird wild
durcheinander sondiert und wenn sie zu
hause jetzt denken kein mensch kann
wissen wie das am ende ausgeht stimmt
gar nicht spoiler alarm
zdf spezial
jetzt spürt die doppel holte show auch
noch die kompletten
koalitionsverhandlungen genauso sieht es
aus albrecht humboldt von der
forschungsgruppe wahlen hat die letzten
3000 koalitionsverhandlungen ausgewertet
und meint er kann exakt vorhersagen was
in den nächsten wochen passieren wird
das ist korrekt oliver man nennt es
wissenschaft heute sprechen also wieder
fdp und grüne miteinander und selbst da
gibt es viel mehr gemeinsamkeiten als
der laie denkt ich finde sie sollten
auch mal fragen stellen cannabis
freigeben ok dann
zwei lustige griff eulen sitzen da
zugedröhnt beispiel glas wurde war so
das sind die knackpunkte der nächsten
wochen die grünen wollen 12 euro
mindestlohn tempolimit vermögenssteuer
mieten deckel und die abschaffung der
privaten krankenkasse die fdp dagegen
will absolut nichts davon aber natürlich
games kompromisse man könnte zum
beispiel sagen vermögenssteuer nur in
monaten mit r als beispiel und beim
tempolimit wird die fdp wahrscheinlich
vorschlagen 210 bei nässe warum nicht
und dann kommt also tatsächlich die
ampel
nein nein natürlich nicht lindner will
jamaika sonst nichts so ist der plan
aber er kann die ampel nicht an den
grünen scheitern lassen weil die braucht
er ja noch
also muss irgendein anderer dödel für
ihn die ampel springt am besten mit
einem richtig bescheuerten interview wer
käme denn da in frage
zum beispiel auf die saskia ist verlass
absolutes ampel hallo jamaika wird aber
leider auch nix als aktuelle umfrage 75
prozent der grünen-anhänger lehnen
jamaika entschieden ab das durchzuziehen
wäre für die parteiführung quasi
ritueller selbstmord sie schaltet also
ein zweites mal die alkoholiker hahaha
bereit mal und dann haben wir also
wieder das was wir immer haben so good
old crow co nur diesmal halt unter spd
führung
doch wollte die letzten drei mal ja auch
keiner kommt trotzdem immer auf eine art
auch superpraktisch man muss nur die
merkel austauschen durch olaf scholz
allerdings nur bis ungefähr februar
wegen der neuen erkenntnisse im comic
skandal diese woche schon wieder
hausdurchsuchung einfach mal googlen und
dann heißt der neue kanzler kevin
kühnert so bittet natürlich werden sonst
ein viertel der neuen spd-fraktion sind
jusos fühlen hat würz und auf dem
kanzler dienstwagen steht dann statt wie
bisher 0 2 einfach nur alpha kevin guten
moment mal
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and card
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich